ma monture
la plus belle du monde
aucune autre à laon
le mardi après midi dans les locaux des
restos du coeur de rambouillet les
coupes sanchez
[Musique]
la gérante du salon sourire et diam's a
contacté l'association il ya trois ans
pour proposer ses services
deux séances ponctuelles elle est passée
cette année un créneau hebdomadaire
consacrée aux bénéficiaires il ya des
personnes qui aident avec des dons il ya
des personnes qui aident financièrement
et puis moi je voulais vraiment aider
avec notre savoir faire car je pars
vraiment sur le principe que être beau
pour un entretien être beau tous les
jours ben ça redonne confiance en soi et
c'est aussi ma façon de collaborer aux
citoyens de rambouillet l'une de ses
employées vient tous les mardis de 14 à
16 heures pourquoi fuir en moyenne seuls
bénéficiaires gratuitement raccourcir la
longueur la neige
je ne suis pas habitué aux séances rico
du mardi après-midi organisé par le
resto du coeur de rambouillet marie
laure a cette fois décidé de passer
entre les mains d'audrey un moment pour
soi idéal pour se sentir en confiance
avant son prochain entretien en bouche
on perd beaucoup son emploi au pied
autre chose et qu'on est dans une
situation jusqu'à aller aux restos du
coeur ça me dire que mais financièrement
on n'y arrive plus belle image de soi
c'est très très important et toujours le
sourire pour la famille pour nous mêmes
les bénéficiaires sont ravis d'avoir
accès à ce service et les sciences quoi
sur d'autres et sont déjà complètes
jusqu'au mois de novembre
[Musique]
à